rare for a while there they were just
kind of doing whatever Microsoft told
them you remake that you already make
that thing do that SEO thieves has been
this project that they've been working
on for a long time sort of sid meier's
pirates mixed with like minecraft or
something looks all right doesn't it
yeah I I've been wanting a good pirate
game for a long time hmm the elements of
like the ship management like we sort
see a guy actually get a captain's cabin
or under fire they actually have to
repair their ship I would definitely
pick us up with some friends and like
create my scallywag crew and go across
the seven seas again it looks like
something might be screwed how many
pirating reference ago my best it does
look again like the kind of thing that
would be less exciting playing like
either with randoms all right shelf yeah
like I would need to be able to maybe
it's just I'm a control freak but I need
to have a group of friends to tell them
what to do I'm the captain of the ship
I'm the captain there I mean yeah it
seems like it's been developed with our
minds they had some hot influences here
playing having a jolly old time what you
thinking about this one run I liked a
lot I thought it was a lot of fun it
might be I'm not sure whether it's the
game or whether it was the influences
playing the game I maybe I just wanted
to hang out with them they seem like a
lot of fun but the know the game seems
like a lot of fun yeah I'm you know the
whole swashbuckling adventure sort of
thing I think there's room for that I'd
like to give it a try yeah i mean i'd
like to know what the sort of the the
objective the grand objective of this
game is i mean some games don't need it
like my crafts all about creating this
game seems to be more about exploration
and like working together so i wonder if
it's gonna be sort of like i would like
this filtered through some sort of like
no man's sky you need to get here got
your finder thing right and the further
you get the harder it gets and maybe
there are massive crowds you to kill
there as well saying everyone loves
right now so you're thinking is going to
be open world I don't know yeah maybe
like it doesn't seem to me like a death
match game like it cuz this thoughts
basic what they showed it was like a
team deathmatch on boat right but like
that this to me must be like a snippet
of what's happening and they grind a
sort of thing what do you think Mike
yeah soon they just showed this
because Cox plays well too yeah kind of
press conferences conferences but I
don't know maybe it's the minimalistic
kind of cartoony art style that doesn't
convince me it's going to be that deep
which I know that's like not at all
indicative of the game systems but it
seems like they're going for a more
surface appeal the pirate thing I mean
like David said earlier if you really by
yourself it'd be kind of funny to see
like a one-on-one thing where the guys
are sprinting between the sales and the
cannon and the wheel it doesn't have me
completely sold I really like like
assassin's creed 4 not not as an
assassin's creed game I like it as a
pirate game all right and if something's
gonna beat that out for me when I have
that itch it would have to be pretty
deep like if you said if it was an open
world where you're actually worried
about like trading and kind of like
having these I don't know hideouts set
up all over the place for your
scallywags as Dave said or whatever that
would that would convince me to check
out this game and put a lot of time into
it but right now I'm not completely sold
on it mmm it's been a good year for
pirate games we played uncharted 4 i'm
looking forward to getting back on the
ship yes more are from see if these
hopefully soon but they haven't got a
really stay for that one either i don't
think but it's coming out windows 10 i
need to play later this week actually
not really yes okay that out yeah let us
know more of your insights onyx on a
gangster calm once I said Xbox calmness